listen to a lot of house music drum and
bass i like guns and roses ac dc what
about like bieber ed sheeran i listened
to ed sheeran i listened to like
listen i was clubbing on i think it was
a friday and the only thing i remember
from the night is at four o'clock in the
morning i was crowd surfing the justin
bieber baby yeah
that was a good one still what's going
on people i'm rd and i'm interviewing
rd
how's it going too bad glad to just stop
yeah so that's the occasion
are you ready
always really
if you were on death row what would be
your last meal
i'd order every single takeaway on the
planet so that i could be there for as
long as possible why are you trying to
get around the rules for you just it's
like three more wishes when someone asks
for free wishes kfc mcdonald's burger
king taco bell so where do you get it
from mcdonald's the whole menu it was
definitely
she can't answer a question big mac
chicken nuggets wraps one one what what
in the meal right before you die what's
the meal you eat a wrap
no you know either enchiladas or vegans
say mexican wave yeah love me some
mexican food describe yourself in three
words confident charismatic
and funny yeah you're so full of
yourself it's a joke all right it's so
funny tell me your joke this doesn't
work
that's kind of funny so what's your
number one chat blind chat player you
know what nowadays they don't really
need to use chat uploading for yourself
all right well back in the day then back
in the day it would just if i could have
stopped a girl just be like yo excuse me
my friends are all laughing at me i know
it seems awkward but i'd be kicking
myself if i saw your face just once and
i never saw you again so i don't know
you don't need it now they just it's
like a what's it called the congo line
just all the way inside vip congo line
into the vip
you're gonna just absolutely wreck
yourself in two years max you're gonna
be done for
yeah so what's your best part edric then
party boy oh i figured everyone went
wild about me doing the whole i can down
the whole syrup bottle i won't be
healthy afterwards but i'll carry on by
again my poetry because i turn the party
up no matter what part it is and
literally i turn the place mashup
that's my party trick i'm gonna make
your party lit for you all right yeah i
like that answer so it's saying hang
over again as always yeah mm-hmm
yeah so what's your hangover
a beer a beer i don't know if you can
get your beer you know you wanna be
them a here
yeah that and a curry so where were you
last night and what time did you go to
bed
six in the morning maybe half six not
responsible is it i had a photo shoot at
nine in the morning feeling fresh though
come on the car through hey
you have to see it all my boy we got you
back to bear
oh lovely
lovely
why did i get the alcohol free one it's
on the pipe
maybe you are funny slightly
that tastes like swimming pool who is
your guilty pleasure like listen to
anybody that people might not expect but
i listen to a lot of different music i
listen to a lot of house music drama
bass i like guns and roses ac dc what
about like
ed sheeran i listened to ed sheeran i
listened to like
listen i was clubbing on i think it was
a friday and the only thing i remember
from the night is at four o'clock in the
morning i was crowd surfing the justin
bieber baby
that was a good one still literally just
travelling because it was mad it's never
my tune so why are you topless why have
you put your top on because i'm doing an
interview
jesus christ she literally don't care
about it
let's let's move on so where do you see
yourself in five years time on top of
the world
either that or buried under it from the
way that i party but no yeah is that
would it
yeah i got the rockstar in me so i made
for a good time not longer yeah
absolutely slammable but yeah so who is
your dream collab dead or alive there's
a feud though obviously michael jackson
just superstardom man i can just stand
on a stage like this and people are
fainting that's crazy that's absolutely
mad i definitely say travis scott
because of the way he captivates the
crowd and getting nicked for insight and
riots based just solely based on the
fact that his show was that lit if you
could date any celebrity which celebrity
would you date date i don't go on dates
that is just not the main point in the
question is it all right if you could be
with anyone be with um margaret robbie
from walter wall street baby as well
mate don't lie about that why her she's
so sexy she's sexy in every film she's
in i can't lie and she's growing as well
but yeah she's a tall girl though tall
girl
that's the only girl that i don't know
good luck so what's your most disgusting
habit oh i've got a few of them give us
a title for the youtube video guys
i don't know i'm quite trying maybe i
don't have that many disgusting habits
as i fall so what's the least you could
say i can't literally go why not i'm you
i know what your bad dab is i don't like
i said maybe it's a disgusting habit but
i don't go on dates
like wow talking to sleep together if
you're lucky what's the biggest thing
that you want to do maybe like i don't
know do they still do woodstock don't
think so about glaston blaster mirror
yeah that's a big one but you know you
know the dmx show where it does at
woodstock or like um freddie mercury's
one yeah the live aid yeah something
like that big attention secrets though
yeah you said man you said so was that a
good interview lovely enjoy yourself it
is pick up unilad for the piss water
tasting alcoholic free
well this guy's so unprofessional he's
falling asleep but just like
do a little rap for you um uh okay yeah
situated in my own lane i'm not in it
for the one time no piercer my train
always on the go
i needed an igloo for my
[Music]
you